Here's the flashlight effect. It's pretty simple to code. We'll look at that in
a second. However, the effect is not very convincing, as the flashlight cannot
currently move around. This is the only addition I made to the fragment shader.
The vViewPosition is the location of surface in view space. Actually, this is
the position negated, but for our purposes, it doesn't matter too much. Since
view space is looking down the negative z axis, and x and y are zero at the
center of the screen, the flashlight always shines at the middle. We can return
early if the surface is outside the given flashlight radius, so that only the
ambient contribution lights the object. I've added the uniform uFlashOffset, a
two element vector that gives the center point for the flashlight. There are
sliders hooked up to it, but the vector is not used in the fragment shader
itself. That's your task. If the X, Y view position in this location are close
enough together, the flashlight should illuminate the surface. Your job is to
change this code. When you're done, your slider should move the flashlight
around. Look in the original course materials for GLSL documentation links. You
can solve this problem with a one line change by using the proper GLSL built-in
function.